this is a production of cornell
university
all right thank you andy for nice
introduction and first of all i would
like to
thanks andy and tony for inviting me for
the seminar
and for giving me this opportunity to
share some of our work we are doing in
asia especially on on weed management
and it's it's a very delighting moment
for me
it's uh you know it's always an honor
you know when you get opportunity to
speak
at your own alma mater so thank you very
much for the opportunity
and the topic of my talk is that
challenges and opportunities for
sustainable weed management in dry sweet
cropping systems uh before starting my
presentation i would like to acknowledge
all my courses
especially dr arkey malik who is a
senior agronomist
at summit right now is retired but
consultant with summit
and andy with who i work very closely on
this project
and many other you know collaborators i
cannot list
because it's a long list and moreover i
also would like to acknowledge the
donors who has funded various projects
and because of those projects we were
able to do
this what i'm going to present today uh
some of the donors uh usaid
and bill and melinda gates foundation
funding csa project which and used to
lead
before moving to cornell and then
various public and private institutions
supporting directly right consortium
through their membership
which i'm leading at erie and then
also swiss agency for development as
they see
their supporting core gap project which
is closing rice hill gap in asia
and philippine government for supporting
water ice project
so what i have done is i have divided my
presentation into three
parts first one is talking about food
security challenges
and weed management issues in dry speed
systems and then
opportunities for sustainable weed
management and
in the end i'll conclude so let me start
with the food security challenges
in india so um one of the challenges
that you know
by 2050 we will be requiring
about 140 million tons of mill rice in
india
compared to current 113 million tons
similarly uh
to meet the demand of wheat 140 million
tons of wheat will be required
currently we are 100 million ton of
wheat
it means that this extra 27 million
tonne of
rice and 40 million tons of wheat we
have to produce with
less resources in future because they
become scarce
with lower environmental footprint and
under changing climatic condition and
that's a big task
but the opportunities are also there one
opportunity is
to reduce the losses caused by weeds
which can lead to higher productivity
and can help in
meeting those targets by 2050 and also
can
uh you know close the profitability gap
if we can reduce the
losses current by weeks and if you look
at the data
in india these are the actual elosis
in rice and wheat actual mean these are
the losses
happening despite the current farmer's
weed management practices
so in in rice in transplanted rice about
14 percent of erosive
in direct city rise about 21 percent
losses
and uh in wheat but 19 in losses
and these are based on the all india
coordinated uh weed management trial
across india
if you look at economic losses by
combining rice and we together about 0.7
billion us dollar annually
so if you can you know reduce these
losses
it gonna close the ill gap caused by
weeds
as well as going to close the
profitability gaps
i'm going to spend some time on talking
about drivers of chains and
how those drivers have changed as
changing the direction of weed science
in asia particularly if you look at
drivers
of change in asia or in india
particularly
the labor and water becomings case
because these resources are scarce and
becoming expensive the production cost
is increasing
leading to lower profit profitable to
the farmers
and climate change to adapt to these
drivers the agronomy is also changing
and if you look at agronomy there's
increased
interest to shift from ptr stands for
pedal transponderize
to dsr stands for directly drive
to address the issue of labor and water
and also there's increased interest to
shift from
flooding to alternate dividing and
drying of water management to say water
transitioning from conventional till to
zero to laser conservation till is to to
reduce the cost of production
uh and also because of uh
you know cost of production and labor
availability is less
as there's increased shifts from hand
weeding based weed control to herbicide
based weed control
and also the new technology like
herbicide tolerance technology
are coming also in in the region
this technology has many advantages but
there are many
weed related issues has emerged under
these new systems
and some of those issues are
in the new system the wheat flour are
more diverse
and it's very difficult to control them
with a single
method and and that's why there's a
higher risk of pelosi due to weeds in
the newer system
there is shift towards wheat flora so
it's difficult to control weed like
we did rice in in direct serious system
because of more and more dependence on
herbicide
to save the coast and labor there's a
risk of herbicide resistance in weed
higher risk of human health and
environmental safety
overall in newer system weed management
is becoming more and more knowledge
intensive
so to address these issues what needs to
be done
uh this is what we're doing in in in the
region basically
uh i think what what we have to do is uh
to develop a reconnaissance system
what i mean uh to reconnaissance system
is that a system which can monitor wheat
fluoride scale
factorize special distribution of
troublesome weed
this system can act as an early warning
system to alert emerging threat
of weed and also
to understand what farmers are doing
what are the knowledge gaps
and based on that we identify the entry
points to close those
knowledge gaps another thing we have to
do is basically to develop and deploy
integrate weed management strategies and
also to create enabling environment for
large scale adoption of sustainable feed
management practices
now i'm going to talk about these three
one by one let me start with the
reconnaissance system for monitoring
weed fluoride scale
and to establish this system uh under
sisa project
we started this landscape diagnostic
survey in collaboration with the kvks
kvks
stands for freshly began kendra's means
agriculture science center
and these are at every district level in
india
for landscape diagnostic survey in rice
we did in eight states
starting from northwest punjab haryana
all the way to the south
covering about 75 districts
with a household of about
more than 14 000 households
in wheat uh we covered five states
and 55 districts roughly about
7 600 households
and these are sampling points and the
for sampling
uh what we did is basically randomly
selected 30
uh villages per district and within
each village we selected seven
households
so roughly 210 household per distinct
in terms of data collection um for for
read purpose
we asked farmers to uh you know
list most common weeds of rice and wheat
and then we ask them to rank them at the
top
five troublesome and for more accurate
weed id
uh what we did is basically we use
postures
with high quality photographs with
mature plants
and then we pre-test it so that farmers
can easily identify
those weeds and familiar about those
weeds
and all agronomic practices were also
collected
production practices with key social and
site factorization
of the data and all this information was
collected from the large
farmer's largest plot and data was
collected digitally
using odk platform
just uh zooming into one state bihar
which is basically uh we covered all the
districts
of bihar 31 districts in bihar was
covered in this survey
and this is the 12 most common weeds
in fasting rice field in 31 districts of
behalf
on y-axis are different districts on
x-axis is basically different weed
species
uh number one means that the most uh
common weed the highest frequency and
twelfth is the twelfth most common weed
and you can see that some weed species
are you know kind of a
cosmopolitan they are present in every
district
um and these are like the weed species
which are
closely associated with rice so if rice
is grown you'll expect these weeds to be
there
but there are many other weeds which are
associated with specific districts
not uh in all districts taking example
of vd-rice
so we do that was reported only in eight
districts
um this is
top five troublesome weeds this is
infesting
bihar and you same results basically
uh there are some weed species like
kainoklava
and there's some perennial wheat some
sages they were
more common across districts but other
weeds were
specific to statistics again take an
example of vd-rice
although uh among top 12 most common
beats was reported in
eight districts but troublesome was
reported only in four distinct
if you look at the spatial distribution
of some of the perennial weeds
cyanodont decline which is a bermuda
grass and cypress rotundus which is a
purple nut says and you can see that you
know
they're kind of identical wherever
cyanogen is present
cyprus rotators is also present so they
follow the trend so
but more interesting uh that now
only in orissa bihar west bengal and
andhra pradesh
these perennial beats for more problem
than other
states and we can look at why
is this we know some of the reasons why
it is but we will look at data more
closely uh
it's linked with uh you know long fallow
in orissa
linked with poor land preparation in
bihar and western goal
and and other for this link the cropping
system so they
after rice they take black gram and the
black gram
is upland crop where you know this
perennial weeds can propagate
so this kind of information now is
coming up that these
perennial wheats are becoming problem so
we need to develop intricate weed
management strategy
for these perennial weeds in these
states
if you look at the video rice it's still
not widely spread
in only few pockets so so this
reconnaissance system connects the early
warning system you can see that
vd rise is an amazing weed it's not
widespread in only
a location and we need to increase
awareness about this
wheat to prevent its spread and we have
to start thinking about developing
solution
so that we are prepared before it
becomes a big problem
if you look at wheat similar story there
are
many weeds like uh peanut butter album
polaris miner poly pogon these are kind
of a
widespread across all districts but
other wheat species are specific to
specific
uh districts overall uh if
what we're getting out of this is this
you know the
special information on the distribution
of problematic weeds
can help us in developing and deploying
appropriate weed management products
in specific districts as per wheat flora
and i'm giving an example of wheat here
if you look at these two wheat species
both
are broadleaf la thyrus alpaca
and solanum negrum and
normally uh no matter substituent is
widely used
metal stone is okay for lath iris but it
will not control solenoid
so for controlling solenoid in those
three districts or four districts
we have to make sure that carpentry zone
is
placed and available to the farmers in
those districts which is not widely
available currently
another example is uh you know flores
miner
and poly pogon these are both grass weed
species
and and you can see that you know sulfur
sulfuron is widely
recommended and it's very effective for
polaris miner
but sulphur sulfuron based mixture will
not control
polyprogram and if polyprogram is
becoming widespread
probably the sulphur supreme will not be
very effective in long run
so we have to think about minoxidil
which is registered in india
but it's not available in bihar state so
we have to think about
deployment of these new products which
can
effectively control the emerging weed
species
so this was about the weed species but
now if you look at
what are the practices farmers are using
to control weeds in
again taking example of bihar state
you'll be surprised to see that
30 percent of the farmers are not doing
anything
for wheat control in wheat crop in bihar
state
and about 50 farmers use herbicide based
weed control
and 20 farmers still using hand weeding
if you zoom in further within bihar
looking at
especially district wise uh the font
with
red color is basically farmers are not
doing
any weed control in which and the black
font is saying basically
farmers are using herbicide based speed
control and the one with the circle
those are the districts where
40 to 60 percent of the farmers not
controlling weed at all
so these are the districts where we can
expect more impact of the weed control
and our energy should be focused on
those districts where
still 40 to 60 farmers are not
controlling weeds
so this kind of information we can get
out of these kind of diagnostic surveys
if you look at the the rise
the current weed management practices um
it's in contrast to which in rice
majority of the farmers
they are controlling weeds by some
methods
more than 95 percent farmers are
controlling weeds in dry
except in chatham's good state still 36
percent farmers are not controlling
wheat
in rice in chapters yet so there's a
need of more awareness
about the importance of weed control in
japanese
but if you look at the the practices and
most of the states in
recent we have particularly more about
seventy percent farmers rely on on hand
reading
and in andhra pradesh west bengal and
uttar pradesh
32 uh you know 45 farmers still
depend on hand weeding and punjab
haryana is mostly
uh you know herbicide-based and if you
look at the
the impact of the weed management
practices on the yield of rice for
example
the hand weeding is the most common as
compared to hand weeding
um what we have seen that rice seals
were higher when farmers use herbicide
based
intricate weed control herbicide based
mean herbicide plus hand weeding
generally and then other like
land preparation stuff like that so six
to
sixteen percent higher yield when they
use herbicide plus hand weeding
as compared to when they rely only on on
hand reading
moreover in many of the eastern states
of india
the harvest side farmers are using are
older herbicide
and they are not very you know
broad spectrum but new herbicides are
available which are safer
and and broad spectrum so we expect with
a newer herbicide even
the effect would be higher the yield
advantage would be higher
so our next step would be you know
doing more special analytics to develop
digital
weed maps and also mapping hot spots for
potential emerging problem whether the
perennial weed species emerging whether
herbicide resistant potentially emerging
or where the vdd rice is emerging so
that's one task and then
we are already working with the national
partners uh
to develop web-based portal with
actionable output
for district or state level extension
agency
uh with entry points to close eel gap
and
improve input use efficiencies
moving to the second topic uh developing
and deploying integrate weed management
so let me go through quickly about
background about rice with production
system
so two crops rice and wheat are grown in
its calendar year
rise dominantly by puddle transplanting
system and this method consists of three
operation
puddling which is a wetlands and you can
see that the intensive tillage
require require a lot of energy and and
water
transplanting where from nursery
seedlings are transplanted when about 30
days old
in the main field and you can see it's a
labor intensive and mostly done by the
government farmers
and then for majority of the period the
fields are kept flooded
require large amount of water this
method has many advantages
particularly for weed control because
flooding control reads effectively
and also ensure good crop establishment
because the seedling is transplanted
but in current scenario many issues are
emerged
um one of you can see that it's the
resource intensive
method it requires intensive challenge
required large amount of labor water and
all these resources are becoming
scarce and expensive overall making this
method
less and less attractive and economical
also flooded rise
are considered a major culprit for
methane emission
one of the key greenhouse gas and
we have seen that puddling is good for
rice but it has adverse effect
on succeeding known rice crop like wheat
so the wheat what we have observed is
ten percent higher
if grown after non-federal rise compared
to after purple rice
so um immediately after rice second crop
of wheat is grown
there is a short turnaround period
between two crops
uh but after puddling farmers do
intensive tillers for fine seed bed
preparation for wheat
and uh majority of the farmers they burn
the residue
just to clean the field and get ready
for planting for wheat
so the major issues with the wheat are
its intensive challenge leads to late
planting and you can see that
uh the relationship between planting
date and wheat eel so the
delay the planting the drastic reduction
they beat eel
burning of residue leads to
environmental pollution
greenhouse gas emission and nutrient
loss and
polaris minor one of the imposed
important weed of wheat
has evolved resistance to many
herbicides
what we need is basically alternate
methods
which are labor what and cost effective
and have a lower environmental footprint
these are the some of the alternate
options
for rice and wheat and in rice it's a
dry seed rice
is one option in which dry seed is sown
directly in the main field
in non-pedal condition whereas the wet
seeded rice is basically
pre-generated seeds are shown on
directly in the main field
in the puddle field so land preparation
is similar to potato transplant rice
only crop establishment is changing
because in dry dsr both
land preparation and and crop
establishment
dry dsr is more common where labor and
water are becoming scarce
wet seeded rice is more common where
water is still
available but labor becoming issue
for wheat zero till sweet is a you know
good alternative and these are the
different benefits of these technologies
the dsr
i don't need to go through but you can
read it resource saving higher income
time saving good for soil health and
lower and global warming potential
but there are trade-offs and their
trade-off is linked with the weed
management
so weeds are one of the major
constraints in large scale adoption of
these technologies
because if you save labor you save water
you save tillers i mean you cannot go to
everything
you know benefit right they are
trade-offs we are the trade-off
and therefore there's a need to develop
integrated weed management practices
which are effectively profitable
sustainable so that these practices can
be
adopted widely
so now i'm going to talk about
integrated weed management
and iwm is basically integration of
multiple
practices in weed science we call a many
little hammer approach
which is more sustainable and effective
and is built on around strong foundation
of weed ecology and weed biology
instead of using a single method like
chemical weed control
a large hammer which is not sustainable
now one of the opportunities for weed
management iwm in wheat
um quickly on on major weeds of wheat
in dry speed system polaris minor
little candy grass is the most important
weed
which can cause eel floss up to 80
and this weed species has evolved
resistance to
majority of the herbicide registered in
india
particularly in northwest part of india
punjab and haryana
so it's a really really big problem in
addition to forest miner these are other
common weeds
found in which in right speed system
in terms of opportunities the biggest
opportunity with us is zero tail is
zero delays is basically expresses
emergence of virus minor
and you can see this is the study done
uh
on on x axis we have the seed bank and
top 10 centimeter
layer and on y axis is the amount of
seedlings of pilates miner
and you can see the first second and
third floors the emergency slate of
polaris miner is
lower in in zero till as compared to
conventional village
roughly 50 percent lower emergence rate
in
first plus and third class so first plus
is very important from crop feed
competitive point of view
also early wheat sowing combined with
rice residue mulch
suppresses the emergence of lightest
miner and other wheat species so that's
another opportunity
to control uh weed in wheat and if you
see the relationship of
planting dates with the flores minor
density
and tenth number is the basically the
optimum date
and early around 25 october
when you plant about 68 lower emergence
of solaris miner
compared to optimum landing dates and
about 80 lower compared to
late planting of each and if you see the
relationship between
florist minor emergence and the residue
mulch
um you know for polaris miners to stress
you need about six ton of uh
residue mulch and with six ten and more
than six ton
it can reduce forty five percent to
seventy five percent lower emergency
planets minor
and when when you combine both early
plant
and the residual moles you can express
about 80 to 95 percent of polarized
minor
so instead of burning residue it's good
to use
residue for for mulching which will help
in suppressing the wheat as well as
conserve the soil moisture and now
machines are available
uh happy cedar which can establish wheat
in full residue of rice so that's
basically uh by by happy cedar
residue mulch early planting we can
almost eliminate fluoresce miner
you can look at the effect of residuals
on other weed species
similar to last study but we found that
for fluoresce mineral units six ton or
above
but other weed species are more
sensitive even four ton
residue drastically reduce their
establishment
but we have also found that zero till is
uh with residue
also uh enhanced post-dispersal seed
predation of vladis minor
and you can see that the seed predation
was sixty percent uh
in in zero tillage compared to ten
percent in in conventional fields
and this is what we found the empty
seeds was eaten by the by insects
if you continuously use gerotillas with
residue it can leads to depletion of
feed seed bank
and this is what we did is basically
cropping system trial long-term trial
where one is basically a conventional
system
and a vessel transmitter is four by
conventional beach
two is basically uh rice is parallel
transponding but wheat is zero tillage
with residue
three is the rise and which both are
under no till
and ford is diversified system maize
floored by wheat
and you can see that uh with continuous
zero dealers
but after four years uh seed bank
ninety two hundred percent we depleted
the seed bank of politics minor
for other species about 70 to 100
reduction in feedback there was no uh
you know kind of reduction in
significant reduction in seed bank of
anarchalis arvensis despite the
declining trend
the reason is basically because
anarcholis arvensis has a longer
longevity
in the soil you can see the the
longevity of different weed species
we have seen so anagallis can survive
longer in the soil
and and probably uh after few years we
will
this will reflect and feedback but in
the field we didn't see enough
arvensis because anarchist is also very
sensitive to residue mulch
and this is what we found after three
years but we see that
the clean field of wheat and there is no
fluoresce miner under conservation
agriculture based system
whereas in in conventional till you see
a lot of politics minor
and in this long-term experiment after
three years of wheat
uh we basically didn't spray any
herbicide
so for three years we skipped three
years uh no herbicide after
in year four five and six so based on
these results we can say that you know
after three years of uh you know early
planting of which with conservation
agriculture
you can skip herbicide for two to three
years and then some some bits started
coming up probably you have to again
apply some herbicide for a few years
moving to direct seed rice
the weeds are big problem in dsr
why if you look at transplanted rice
so these are three operations i
discussed puddling which
uh control weeds early stages for during
that preparation time
transplant has a give a head start to
the crop
because of age advantage 30 days older
seedlings
versus emerging wheat species and in
transplant rice you can
use early flooding in the day of
transplanting and which is effective
herbicide
but in in dsr and dry dsr we
we lost all these three operations which
was the option for weed control
in transparent rice so dry dsr is no
puddling
and directly so on so there's no
advantage of seedling is
and dsr is sensitive so rice is
sensitive to early stage of
germination in the merger so we cannot
flood the field for weed control early
in dsr that's the disadvantage with the
sr
so that's why there's more wheels in wet
dsr
puddling is still option but advantage
of transplant
and early flooding is gone that's why
there's a more weeds
in dsr high that's why farmers are more
dependent on the herbicide
leading to higher wheat control cost and
greater risk of free losses
what are the opportunities how we can
manage weeds in dslr
first one is soil mulch dsr
which can inhibit recruitment of weeds
and also save irrigation water
uh let me explain what soil mulch is
it's a very simple
uh you know economic adjustment so this
is the standard practice of dsr
normally a field is prepared and then
rice is sown in in dry condition and
then immediately after seeding
there is a you know irrigation supply
and this irrigation is
basically to ensure good crop
establishment
but this irrigation also created best
condition for wheat to emerge
so along with rice weeds are also
melting
so ah what we did is basically adjust a
little bit
instead of you know using
uh irrigation after seeding
uh use pre-sowing irrigation so
preserving irrigation will initiate weed
to germinate
and then when the field is under
conditioned field condition
then you prepare the field with the
tillis and the tillers will kill those
emerging weeds and will also
break the capillaries and then
in that moist condition you see the crop
and then have a light flanking
and you delay first irrigation for two
to three weeks
and this pill is basically
they break the capillary and created the
soil mulch
soil surface dries two to three
centimeters very quickly
in couple of hours where the most of the
weeds are sitting
so that's why there's a very low
germination or emergence of weeds
but moisture is conserved below 3
centimeter
where the rice seeds are sitting so in
this way we can save
moisture and save irrigation and
reduce the recruitment of weed emergence
and this is the results you can see this
is the soil mulch dsr
which is established after pre-sowing
irrigation and this is established after
uh irrigation immediately after seeding
and you can see that
crop is you know lines are very clear
there's no weeds in between rows
whereas in this scenario and a lot of
weeds are
growing that's why the lines are not
visible
so what we found about 50 to 65
lower v density in weed biomass which
ultimately led to higher yield of rice
under dsr
in punjab we did another study to
optimize
when to irrigate you know first
irrigation under so much dsr
right whether is it two weeks is right
time or three weeks night time
where there is an ill penalty if you
delay further
so what we found that uh you know
uh whether you irrigate immediately
after seeding
after soil mulch dsr or two weeks or
three weeks
yields are similar but you get advantage
in terms of weed control
so 65 lower weed density indeed biomass
when you delay first irrigation by 14
days
or 21 days and as you delay the
irrigation
uh compared to applying immediately
after seeding
there's six percent water saving if you
deliver two weeks
and about twelve percent water saving if
you delay by three weeks
another opportunity is to identify weed
competitive
and high yielding rice varieties and
this study was done in
bihar patna at csr research platform
and it was a split plot
experiment their main plot was duration
of wheat competition
starting from five days after seeding to
maturity
maximum competition from 15 days
to maturity 30 days to maturity
simulating different pluses of weeds
and no competition weed free and then we
use
11 varieties a mix of hybrids
and inbred so in shorter duration
category one hybrid one in bread
as a check and then in medium duration
category
we use six hybrids and one in red check
and in long duration category we use two
in bread because there's no
long duration hybrids and in this study
we use purple rice as a kind of a
surrogate wheat so that we can maintain
the same density across treatment
and we planted purple rice between rice
rows at five centimeters spacing
and if you look at the results it's very
interesting you know
hybrids were more weed competitive and
they
are very high yielding as well so you
can see that these two hybrids
particularly
their highest yielding and they
and this is like a different duration of
weed competition so they maintain very
high yield
even under full competition you know
five days to maturity in
variety five hybrid only fourteen
percent
loss is under full weight competition uh
another variety is
uh is v6 which is also maintained high
yield
and under weed free conditions very high
yield
this is another variety which also
very weird competitive only 70 elosis
but under wheat free condition is not
very high yielding
so that troll is good under like
uh where the weed control is poor but
but not good under those conditions
where farmers can manage weeds better
but other inbred varieties are very
sensitive to early weed competition you
can see the elos is
50 to 80
but if you can control weeds for 15 days
then these varieties are you know can
maintain high yield
so
overall hybrids were more wheat
competitive and higher yielding
and you can see the advantage of hybrids
over inbred varieties
under different duration of weed
competition so 120
higher yield when you have a full
competition
uh with hybrid compared to inbred and
otherwise it's about 10 to 25 ill
advantage
in hybrids and but we found that 36 to
53
lower weed biomass under hydrates
because
of the weird competitiveness
we also looked at what are the traits
responsible for weed competitiveness in
this hybrid
and we did this path analysis
to identify the trait what we found
in an early wheat biomass accumulation
by the rice variety
is the the key trait and can be used for
screening varieties for wheat
competitiveness
of course early weed biomass
accumulation is controlled by multiple
traits like uh leaf area index uh
tillering capacity canopy cover
uh plant height all these are the
factors but if you look at one trait
that's the early biomass and so early
biomass can be used
to screen varieties for weed
competitiveness under weed free
condition
another opportunity is to use early
flooding for wheat expression using
anaerobic germination tolerant rice
spice varieties
i was telling in in dsr one of the
problem is
you know we cannot flood the crop early
to express the wheat because rice is
sensitive
at germination and emergency stays once
the crop is a must you can flood it
but erie has been doing
research and they have identified
donor varieties with anaerobic
germination tolerance
and they have integras that that trade
into mega varieties like ir64
and you can see that this is ir64
variety with anaerobic germination
tolerant rate
so even if you flood it it can establish
very well
uh without edgy tolerance treat the poor
establishment
so with edgy tolerant variety with uh
we can do the early flooding for weed
control
which leads to good establishment as a
as well as a good weed control
we looked at uh you know in wet seated
rice
the the effect of early flooding
so if you look at the saturated
condition we use
all the varieties established very well
but you can see a lot of weeds are
popping up
between the rows um
when we did two centimeters of early
flooding immediately after seeding
with aeg torrent varieties establishment
is good but
weed control is also good you won't see
any weeds emerging right
in six centimeter flooding establishment
is good
and there's no weeds so basically what
we found that you know
you don't need six centimeters of
cutting two centimeter flooding it
itself is good
uh and what we found is 48 hours after
seeding is
better than doing immediately because
immediately
you do flooding still there's a poor
establishment
so early flooding effectively control
weeds
with anaerobic germination total
varieties we can control uh in dsr
we also looked at integra interaction
between flooding and
and herbicide and you look at no
flooding
no herbicide so there's a lot of weeds
and crop is coming when we used
one-fourth rate of platelet load it's a
pre-emergent service site
and no flooding you can see the rice are
not now visible
and weeds are controlled but still small
wheats are there
i mean with half rate of recommended
further you know you can see the weed
control is improved
with full rate uh there's slightly
toxicity on rice and but weed control is
further improved
because and and if you look at this
two centimeter flooding again uh
very less weeds are there and when you
have
two centimeters of flooding and one
fourth rate of petrochlor
there's hardly any weeds so what we
found is that you know there's a
positive interaction of herbicide into
water
and herbicide dose can be reduced if
combined with early flooding
and we found uh greater than 95
reduction in v density and biomass when
stellar particles combined with
low dose of herbicide
we've been doing a lot of work on
herbicide screening also and
based on multiple location uh what we
found that
using pre-emergent service site flowed
uh post emergence and one
sport hand weeding or mechanical reading
can control weeds effectively
in dsr and these are the different
options i don't need to go in detail
what is important is that in the past we
were using herbicide selection based on
the quotient efficacy
but it's important to uh you know select
this herbicide also based on their
environmental impact
and i use this you know kernel resource
to estimate the
environmental impact questions of
different herbicide
based on the field use rate and these
are the rice herbicide
and you can see that majority of the new
herbicides
have a lower environmental impact
compared to the older herbicide like 240
or
bendy methylene similarly in wheat
isoprotein is the the
old herbicide highest environmental
impact
but newer herbicide have a lower
environmental impact
and now we are recommending this
herbicide based on on these
environmental impact the data
another opportunity is to integrate
mechanical
reading because mechanical reading can
can save
labor and you can see the the cost of
mechanical reading is about 500 rupees
per hectare whereas in manual reading is
about 2 000 to 3 000 rupees
one of the prerequisite for mechanical
reading is you know
line sewing so
mechanical dsr facilitate that it's
establishing a line and we can use
mechanical reading
whereas in transparent rice it was
random transplanting
so mechanical reading was not possible
it's just an opportunity
with line establishment of dsr
my final quickly on enabling environment
for large scale adoption so we are using
for
for dissemination of some of these
practices uh using
existing ict platform so erie has
developed
uh one of the icd platform rice probe
manager mainly for
nutrient management now we established
we developed the weed modules and we
have integrated weed modules
in this crop manager so along with
nutrient management now the
recommendation is also going for the
weed management and we tested it but the
impact of read modules
on the productivity so we this is t1 is
a formal practice
of nutrient management and weed
management t2 is
same except weed management as per our
recommendations through crop manager
t3 is only a recommendation of crop
manager for nutrient management
and t4 is you know recommendation of
nutrient
and weed management as per crop manager
and we found eight percent higher yield
with our newer recommendation
and when you combine nutrient and weed
management 22 percent higher yield
we are also uh you know developing a
android based speed app
which is under development and our idea
is that you know
with the photographs farmers and tick
mark
which are the major weeds in their field
uh multiple weed species
and then the recommendation should be
based on the wheat flora
of the complex wheat flora with multiple
options
and and other than herbicide but could
be other
cultural practices which can be used
so this is under development um
also uh capacity development market
development of new products
and strategic partnership is critical
for scaling
so we have already developed a lot of
training modules
outreach material and um you know
we having a in a strong partnership with
private sector
to to deploy these new products in in
those geography where market development
are poor
and because of multiple efforts
uh in the sisa project we have reached
about 1.2 million households
uh are practicing this effective and
safe speed control practices
in about 1.3 million hectare area
another opportunity emerging is drone
technology
because in the past uh you know we are
struggling with
training farmers to to use safety and
farmers are not using safe
safety while applying herbicide in in
asia
so drone technology will take care of
that because there's
no human involved in spraying so
uh and also open up opportunity for
site specific application as well
let me conclude reducing yield gap
caused by weed of
a great opportunity to address the food
security challenge
and weeds are the biggest constraint in
large-scale adoption of
in the new system an effective iwm
program will
facilitate wide scale adoption of these
resource sufficient
crop personalized methods thank you very
much i hope
i didn't go too much over time
thank you so much you covered a
tremendous amount of
of turf there if you're still awake i'm
sure
there there are a couple of questions
from the floor um
we can limit them to two in interest of
your uh
your general health and well-being um
but let me open the floor would anybody
like to ask
render a question go ahead and unmute
i have a question if there aren't any
other questions i have
a small question i was curious about um
the stale seed bedding so where you pre
irrigate and then you do a light tillage
to create a dust mulch
i was wondering if you know what tool
they're using to make such a fine dust
mulch only two or three centimeters
so uh thank you for the question uh we
are not using special tool this is
normal
um you know killer's operation
and the tillage is around five to
seven centimeter but
what is happening is basically the top
two centimeter layer is
drying up and below its moisture is
conserved
so it's not that we are only dealing two
to three centimeters is going up to five
to seven centimeter
but uh that kill is creates surface
mulch and and then uh top two sentiment
dries very quickly because of
high temperature around 40 degrees
celsius at the time
and and then the capillary is broken so
moisture lost is
stopped because of that surface soil
mulch
thanks and are they are they using like
a disc or i i saw that one
i know that some sometimes when they're
puddling they'll use a rototiller
um what do they use for this yeah
you i mean farmers are using uh
harrowing and
even rototiller yeah motivator
okay thanks
brender there's a general comment that
they're just giving you thanks for a
wonderful presentation
and also saying that you gave so much to
chew on that
it has to also begin so i think that
there's there may be more
request questions upon reflection but
uri i don't know if you're connected
still are you do you want to give one
more shot at asking a question otherwise
we should probably close
because we're we're approaching five
minutes over
ah okay hang on one sec so lori's
question rendering this is the last one
we'll take
is that i imagine that nitrogen
limitation is an issue in both the
flooded rice systems
due to leaching and the mulch system due
to end tie up from the wheat
decomposition do you have any sense for
for which a pro approach has less
possibility
for end stress and rice
and stress i think i mean
it's not a big problem in in dslr for
the system but i think
slightly more available in in better
systems because of the
the ph which get close to neutrality
um but the losses are higher different
kind of losses so in
in dry direct seeding rice is a more
nitrous oxide losses
because of more aerobic condition
whereas in
i think blood system more
[Music]
ammonia verbalization losses are more so
the losses are different
slightly uh i mean probably
right now we're using same same
fertilizer of nitrogen
but probably uh you know time of
application we
normally advise one extra split of
nitrogen in
in dsr or
maybe one booster dose of poly
replication
that's how we we're doing it but
generally
nitro is not a big problem
micronutrients become a big problem
particularly micronutrients like iron
and gene
under that extreme system yeah thank you
great thank you so much frinder we
really
deeply appreciate you coming in today
and staying up till 2 30 in the morning
so virtual round of applause for you and
we look forward to having you
at cornell over the summer but thank you
everybody for
for joining today and welcome back to
the semester thanks again brender
thank you very much for the opportunity
yeah
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu